welcome to cloud on air live webinars
ploud we are hosting webinars every
Tuesday
my name is Manju Devdas and today I'll
be talking along with Cisco about how
air enables enterprise digital
transformation along with deeper
customer insight you can ask questions
anytime on the platform and we have
Googlers on standby to answer them let's
get started so shortly I will be
introducing some of my co speakers
Sanjeev Patel and Vikram and together we
will be talking about the how AI and AI
enables enterprises with digital
transformation deeper customer insight
before that let me give you a little bit
of background about myself
I'm Manju Devdas have worked for 17
years
in predictive analytics as technology
has evolved the computation and memory
gets cheaper the power of technology now
used in analytics and this
decision-making has now started to
change transformation in now started or
transform businesses in ways that now
has been classified as the fourth
Industrial Revolution and I'll between
myself and my Co speakers will try to
give you enough insights so that you can
see why the industry looks at it that
way with some real-life enterprise
examples so quick introduction about
Pluto 7 we are Google's preferred
partner when it comes to machine
learning and expertise it's not just
about technology it's also understanding
business and and driving business to
change that's the transformation in the
retail supply chain and manufacturing
that's how the joint partnership between
Google and Pluto 7 is helping many
customers before we go into machine
learning in the eye I'm sure a lot of
you are reading about machine learning
and AI whether it's magazine television
and so on you are now talking with
Google on Google's platform everything
that Google does is machine learning and
the IB Gmail your YouTube your photos
and so on now
what does that mean when you apply
in an enterprise context let's try to
simplify it a bit right so if you if you
look at simple decision-making that
happens in a human brain it's really
three simple things that happen
you gather information you process the
information
you make a judgment the way you make a
judgment about whether what day it is
what should I wear is no different from
a process point of view in terms of how
you make a decision in an enterprise is
this remember is the same human being
what decisions you make at home and what
your decisions you make an enterprise
the whether you talk in the context of
you know the mimicking the brains
decision-making process it's very
similar right so now a I and Machine
rolling learning is really mimicking
that decision-making process now when it
comes to humans we are biological
creatures so we have our limitations in
terms of how we make decisions or
objectivity and and or a period of time
as we gain experience in our business
our career we build biases about beat
about demand planning forecasting supply
planning knowing our customers
experience we build our believe who is
what's a good market to go after what's
not a good market what's a product that
is profitable or not and then we have
our personal biases in my industry
experience working with many customers I
work for including Cisco whom we will be
listening to very soon as a company we
have served companies like GE Apple
Target and many many more about in my
career about 30 companies so that I have
helped with business transformation
especially our on forecast accuracy I've
found that you know thirty percent of
forecast accuracy is pretty common in
certain industries and if you think
about it and when I really look at why
that happens it's got a lot to do with
human bias and now when you start to
start looking at the same thing from an
evolution from a machine learning and AI
standpoint we are talking about still
the same time series modeling and and
with that you know like how you make
your decision how do you project what
weather is gonna be at what accuracy
level is the same methodology or
approach that you take when it comes to
making business decision if you're
making a time-series decision which is
like commonly known understood as
regression analysis you are applying
those decisions around how much you're
gonna sell which customer is interacting
with you on your website and so on what
what's the propensity to buy lot of
these kind of decisions now you you take
the data and you blend that with your
own ideologies beliefs emotions and and
and logic and you come to conclusion
however when it comes to machine
learning and the I we try to keep those
biases away biases till play a role
because data sometimes has imbedded
biases in them however what we do here
is with machine learning and I we tried
to make help enterprise make more and
more decisions through objective data
pattern analysis that's the power of
machine learning and AI now when in my
experience I work with various customers
they want to automate their factories
there they're looking at human traffic
movement and various including health
devices and medical devices human
medical analysis and so on in this
variety of industry that we serve one
thing that is common is is data silos
and complexity of decision-making and
volumes of decision-making these these
kind of are pretty common themes and
when you look at this as the larger the
enterprise that you get many of you can
relate that these data silos sometimes
create its own challenges in your
decision-making and when you do it at
scale now you have to structure your
organization's differently have people
in fact differently amongst them and so
on all of this in the current world when
we look at at I deal with a lot of
retail companies when you look at the
bottom line KPIs and look at what's
really happening in the business this
could lead to whether it's poor
forecasting
or excess or shortage of supply or
really and not even though they have a
lot of data not really understanding the
customer well enough we are living in
the world of of e-commerce digital
commerce where companies like Amazon
Walmart calm and and Flipkart or Baidu
world and many many more around the
world are now talking about real-time
knowing your customer real-time analysis
real-time sentiment analysis you take
the same learnings and apply that in
your enterprise context you now have the
same power when it comes to machine
learning and AI on a Google cloud
platform I run a lot of executive
c-level executive workshops and
presentations helping them transform
their business some of the common
questions that we get asked is hey we
hear all about machine learning and AI
but how do I use that to understand or
engage my customers better what's the
magic behind it right
does it really help my efficiencies go
up and and so on right so there are a
lot of questions in their mind for it's
really about this paradigm shift right
if you let humans make decisions of
course humans use a lot of softwares and
so on but it may have proven that you
have 60 to 80% accuracy now you look at
shipping your KPIs whether it's your
sales performance or marketing
performance or supply chain performance
to get your accuracy that could not be
imagined possible right now if you have
and sometimes when we walk into a
customer site they say we have all kinds
of software and now what's really a big
deal with machine learning in the I to
give you an analogy if I ask this person
on the left to carry 2000 bricks and go
up that building and put it in one hour
you would say you're crazy I'm not being
I'm not gonna be able to carry that but
with the crane you don't think that's a
big deal when it comes to decision
making simple decision-making in an
enterprise it could be about processing
invoice or it could be around deciding
which customer to run an email campaign
on when you do it through traditional
means
you run into limitations on the left you
really need to now think about scale on
the right right even if I say ten
thousand breaks it doesn't matter right
as in it's that's that's the power that
you get that's the paradigm shift now
again it's easy for me to walk show you
a an analogy but when it comes to
enterprises you have to think about how
how these machine learning gets embedded
in different parts doing simple tasks
initially right before so that humans
can trust and interact and depend
whether it's a recommendation for upsell
cross-sell or a recommendation to focus
on certain set of customers you have to
make it part of your business when we
walk into a customer site sometimes
innovation and machine learning goes
hand in hand and our customers asked hey
how can I use machine learning and AI so
we have run into scenarios after
scenarios may improve the taste of beer
right do it for one of the largest beer
manufacturer in the world right now that
sounds magical but if you look at the
story behind it it is really crunching
massive amount of data crunching the
data analyzing and coming up with
patterns similarly when you beat
forecast accuracy by 20%
it looks magical it finds hard to
believe but once you double-click and
show how you do it it now you know that
you know you've really started the
journey of machine learning in DI to a
new paradigm things like people get
amazed how does Amazon deliver exactly
on the same day when they say or Walmart
do and so on right the same kind of
capability now you can enable in your
ecosystem in your enterprise now that
requires of course they know it of
thinking then comes one you know your
customers better when you are able to
understand the sentiments and analyze
that better how can you change how the
customer better through price
adjustments these are different
innovations that our customers are
thinking and and acting on now whether
you have picked three of the most common
scenarios here customer engagement we'll
talk a lot about that along with Cisco
and now some very fascinating story as
well as some great speakers coming up
now along with
when you look at you know problems like
forecast accuracy of preventive
maintenance it's really up to you how
much you how far can you imagine within
your ecosystem take the most mundane
task and translate that into an ml model
understand this journey and to drive
home this point today we are gonna focus
on customer engagement and really
understand what does it mean to
understand your customer better
how are your customers interacting if if
the data is you hear this story very
often data is a new oil if you believe
in that statement and if you think about
how Google internally operates Google
has the most amount of data practically
in the world and it's phenomenal how
Google search engine works or or and so
on right there's it's all powered by
machine learning and AI in various forms
and are the same same concepts can be
extended into your enterprise think
about how to use the power of your data
in your in a centralized location where
you can mine the insights and make
decisions on behalf of humans better
than humans in every regard this is not
about replacing Hubert's this is about
empowering and making human superhumans
so in the retail context we are all used
to this getting recommendations hey you
might like this shirt or you might like
this product and and so on so or when
you're watching movies on Netflix you
watch this so you might like that right
in in in in machine learning languages
simple classification problem and
sometimes is a classification and a
regression problem solved music
tensorflow
hosted on Google Cloud ml with your data
centralized in bigquery
I just rolled out a simple solution for
you on this verbally it's really as
simple as putting those Lego blocks
together with these kind of a simple
architecture now you can think of
practically any amount of customer
history your reviews sentiments whether
it's online reviews or what they're
saying on Twitter or social media you
can centralize that without worrying
about scale and capacity when you start
thinking about centralizing your
information and now making your
organization think differently what's
important for you to realize is
that this is not a one-time project it's
a journey
but and when you pretty soon you'll be
listening from Sanjeev the journey
between myself and Sanjeev and Vikram
started really with the conversation
around why do you need to worry about
all this infrastructure and so on so
there is why not centralize the data at
least for your specific business
problems and let's start it there with
something as simple as that
to see them evolve is is amazing Cisco
is a fantastic company with all kinds of
complexity and when you start getting
into these kind of journey it's very
important that you one you select the
right platform do you you blend the
domain knowledge and expertise to really
take the machine learning and put it
into practical use this is not a sci-fi
project anymore for enterprises and and
with with all the experience that we
have gained and we continue to gain
around the world what we are going to
see in the next decade is bigger than
the internet internet revolution with
that I'm proud to bring onstage Cisco
will walk you through their journey and
please welcome sanjay patel who leads
the data sciences organization as well
as vikram police the machine learning
and AI practice at cisco Sanji vikram
thanks Manju it's great to be here as
much you said I'm Sanjeev Patel
I lead a data science group focused on
the customer partner and sales
experience and I've become I'm
technically but for this particular
program so today I want to talk to you
about omni-channel
and some of the challenges that we've
had and how we've worked through those
and so I'll take you back to a few years
ago when Vikram and I were thinking
about ways to get our new customer
success organizations started and what
we noted is that in starting the
customer success organization we were
opening up many new channels and the
challenge that we were having is that
these channels were often disjointed
from the other channels
that we had and it could you know
potentially led to is customers could
engage with certain channels and do that
in a way that was completely separate
from their experience in another channel
and we what we recognize is that we've
really needed to tie the experience
together from these different channels
now I'm guessing Cisco isn't alone there
right that's probably a pretty common
experience and most b2b companies
because b2b companies are traditionally
not focused on this aspect as much and
as the number of channels has exploded
over recent years and the desire to
connect those channels has increased as
well as the desire of customers to have
sort of more of a b2c experience in in
all of their interactions has increased
it's put a lot of pressure on companies
to change and so we recognized that we
needed to do something that would allow
us to bring the experience together in
some way and so that regardless of the
channel the customer chose to engage
with us through they would have a
consistent and personalized experience
but we really wanted to make sure it
took place is that when a customer used
a certain channel that channel was able
to interact with the customer in a way
that considered all of the other
interactions that that customer had with
Cisco and brought the most amount of
information back into that engagement so
that it was an intelligent personalized
experience so you know and that leads me
to a couple quotes that are I think very
relevant you know one talking about how
important that customer experience has
gotten to the point where it is even
maybe more important than product and
price as a differentiator the other one
being that AI is playing a bigger and
bigger role in the customer experience
and that's certainly something that
Vikram and I felt was the case when we
what kind of started this journey and we
knew that we needed to build something
based on sort of an AI foundation so
that's what we want to share with you
today
first let me just describe some of the
challenges that we sort of had as we
were looking at the problem statement so
first as I've mentioned already we had
sort of a desire to have an omni-channel
experience I was connected but we saw
that there were certain silos not
everything was fragmented but there were
certain silos that we needed to
figure out how do we pull those back in
as part of an overall experience and by
the way that includes not only just
digital channels but it also includes
sales channels right people who are
engaging with customers and making sure
that those people have the same type of
interaction and that's consistent the
other one was sort of siloed campaign
execution and what I mean here is that
as we would bring a channel online there
would be a team of people working to
enable it but sometimes they didn't have
the right information from what was
going on in other channels and they were
kind of optimizing for that particular
channel so that led to sort of a siloed
approach and that also led to a lot of
kind of labor-intensive efforts as the
people would try to ramp up a channel
they would try to gather data
independently from other channels and
and bring that together so as channel
sort of brew linearly we almost found
that the number of people that were
involved in supporting those channels
grew exponentially right and we wanted
to figure out a way that we could
address that issue really kind of a core
part of the issue for us was the
scattered data issue we just didn't have
we weren't pulling all of this data from
these different channel interactions as
well as new data that we wanted to
include such as you know customer
interactions in our products together in
a way that could support the customer
experience as a result we didn't have
the amount of insights that we wanted to
and we felt like we could do more around
kind of the intelligence around those
interactions to make them more useful to
customers and improve their experience
so you know what we recognized as I
mentioned is we can't do this if we're
gonna build it effectively through just
human decision-making it is you know as
too complex given the portfolio that
cisco has the size of the company the
diversity of the types of customers and
their expectations around the experience
that they would get and so purely human
decision-making was not going to solve
the problem and what we felt like we
really needed was a strategy that
allowed us to sort of have a path to
something scalable and so there were
three pillars of that strategy connected
data connected intelligence and then
automation and so I'll give you examples
of each one of those interns so you have
a sense of what we're talking about so
the first one is around connecting data
and got
and that's a pretty obvious point that
it's important to get data however part
of what I want to talk about is the way
we were kind of gathering data and
connecting it which i think is the
important part and it's where the
machine learning piece really relates so
we were inspired by you know some
examples in the industry where they were
using machine learning to connect data
one of the ones that I very specifically
remember is around hospitals so you know
hospitals do a good job connecting data
together using machine learning you know
it's not possible for them to match
purely on Social Security numbers
sometimes people make up Social Security
numbers it's not possible to match on
just custom patient names sometimes
those names are identical and so they
use machine learning as a way to make
sure that you know the highest
likelihood match is taking place and
they can do that very fast and scalable
well you know similarly we decided to
use you know that approach in connecting
some of our customer data together and
so whether it was connecting sort of
contacts back to accounts whether it was
actually connecting different channel
data together from different groups that
didn't traditionally fit together very
well or even doing kind of operational
matching of data we started to really
embrace this approach of connecting data
and what we found is that it was a three
of big advantages right one is it was it
was much more accurate this chart gives
you a sense of sort of some of the
accuracy that we found when we were
comparing the human based approach to
the machine learning based approach it
was also much more fast right so we were
able to do this quickly within a matter
of days as opposed to taking a lot
longer than that and it was very
flexible to change so as data changed
which changed changes pretty much
constantly you didn't have to go back
through human process to figure out how
to deal with that change you were
actually able to adapt to that change
very quickly and see that these were all
the big advantages and the connecting
the data became foundational to the
intelligence work that we wanted to do
the other thing that we spent a lot of
time doing is around understanding
intent and so I think you know we're
here Google Google does that really well
with their search engine right if you go
in and you type in the words C is letter
C il cow
google search engine Google knows that
you're looking for the University of
California at Berkeley which is not
intuitive to you know people who are
outside of the United States and the
reason they know that is because
millions of searches has been done in
which intent has been established well
you know similarly we started looking at
problems that we could apply a similar
type of logic to and there are many of
them one of them is the fact that you
know at Cisco we have a broad portfolio
of products and we tend to sell
solutions to business customers and
those solutions are not just one
specific product they tend to be groups
of products all sold together and one of
our problems was establishing when is
when is this what is a solution been
sold to a customer that is kind of the
same for two different customers meaning
you know customer a may have bought
products a B C and D customer B may have
bought products EF G and H but they may
be the same solution right and so how do
we match those two as the same solution
so what we did is we looked at five
million deals in which we looked at what
customers had purchased and we started
looking at the groupings of those
products not just what was purchased but
then what are kind of what do what do
what do we do multiple people purchase
when they're you know kind of purchasing
from Cisco and how do they kind of group
together and we were able to use that in
a number of different ways first you
know the grouping became an input into
things like our models it also became a
good thing to augment feedback from
product managers who were telling us how
to look at solutions at Cisco so and we
were able to use it in a number of other
things as well but this became sort of
some foundational work we could do from
a data side in preparation for the next
step which was the intelligence piece so
you know next I want to talk about the
scalable intelligence and this is
effectively what I'm gonna go into is
kind of the AI and machine learning
aspect of things the thing that I want
to emphasize here is that you know
there's really kind of two strategies
that we had one was around inbound so
when customers come to us we want a way
to kind of classify what their interest
is and we want a way to respond to it as
automatically as possible and as
intelligently as poss
well taking into account all the
information that we have about them
through things like chat bot or
something like you know those types of
mechanisms we also however want to be
able to route those inbound interactions
to people so if there are people who
should be involved we want the ability
to do kind of the routing to the right
person and then we want the person to be
enabled with the right set of priorities
around how to respond to those and what
to say in the interactions to be as
successful as possible so that's how
we're thinking about our inbound kind of
AI vision if you will from an outbound
perspective we want to be able to make
sure that when custom and we're pushing
out things like emails to customers we
want to make sure that it's part of a
journey but that journey what we want to
be able to do is increasingly make that
a data science driven journey meaning
that we are determining the right
content the right timing for that
content and you know the right
positioning in that content so that the
customer ultimately is getting what they
want and we are making sure that that
you know we're engaging with that
customer you know manner that makes
sense for them as opposed to you know
it's kind of a generic journey for us
and so this development of sort of data
science driven journeys is something
that we're still working on and and in
the process of doing so let me share a
couple examples with you around sort of
some of the things we're doing around AI
machine learning that you know I think
may be interesting so the first one is
around Amazon and you know Amazon
predicts a shopper interest based on
their behavior and this is kind of very
well known everybody knows that Amazon
does this and what I found interesting
is that you know Amazon and Airbnb and
many different companies write Spotify
all describe how much of their revenue
is actually based on their
recommendation engine and that's I think
that kind of a fascinating thing in
terms of how important these are so you
know we built recommendation engine as
well looking at kind of historical
product purchasing behavior and what
customers had in their installed base
and the thing that I would that stands
out to me in addition to the ROI of the
model is just how many different places
it has been deployed across Cisco and so
you know from emails
display ads to online even to sales
recommendations we're using it in a
broad variety of ways so that we can we
can get as much leverage out of it as
possible and think about what the
importance of that is in terms of a
consistent customer experience now you
have numerous channels all having
conversations with the customers and
having similar upsell conversations and
that sort of thing with customers it's a
great way to drive consistency the other
example is and I'll use Google again you
know Google uses Google Maps and can
provide sort of optimal routes for you
this optimization piece well that's a
big piece of what we want to be able to
do as well and so one of the things that
we have done is look at how we can use
machine learning and AI to predict what
the best channel to engage a customer is
going to be and so I mentioned that a
little bit earlier in the inbound and
outbound visions of how we how we're
building our kind of AI roadmap and so
in this case we're scoring and customer
engagement through a variety of
different channels and effectively
predicting how we should be engaging
with that customer so for example in
this case if the customer is a very high
email score great we'll use an email but
if it's a low email score and something
else is bigger well we probably won't
email that customer because we know it's
going to be effectively not valuable for
that customer and look to see you know
seek to engage them through other means
the last thing I want to talk about is
automation and you know automation is I
think probably the hardest piece of this
which is how do you take those insights
and how do you put them into these
different channels so that they work and
so I'll describe sort of at a high level
our approach to this you know
effectively what we're doing is we have
a group piloting as new channels are
on-boarded piloting the use of these
models and then we have a group that's
sort of operationalizing that so I'll
talk about that for just a brief moment
we've got effectively two groups and I I
found that this is a really good
practice for us we've got one group
which is a global business team that
seeks to work with channel owners
understand what they're trying to
accomplish has the understanding of the
models that we have so they can bring it
to the
and and give them options in terms of
how they might want to engage with
customers and then comes back to us and
provides you know sometimes requests
sometimes ask requests for support that
sort of thing and so frequently we use
things even something as basic as an
Excel spreadsheet just to get started
and understand how we can serve the
people in that channel better then we
have sort of a deployment team that is
made up of data engineers that's focused
on automating automating that that piece
so how do we get it in so that these
human beings don't have to be involved
in all of the process that that team
that's working on the automation is also
working on how do we drive a regular
cadence of a bee testing and
experimentation so he can make the
engagement through that channel as
robust as possible so with that I will
hand it over to Vikram to talk about
some of the ways that we're we're
handling this from an infrastructure
perspective Thank You Sanjeev and I will
start with Geoff Bowes bizarres
comment he said ai is a horizontal
enabling layer and there is no aspect of
the business very I cannot add the value
now going back to Sanjay's point about
what we are doing and how we are doing
when we vanished when Sanjeev and I
started to look at the vision into
technical aspect we started to lay down
what does it mean from a technical
requirement point of view we had like
hundreds of things but I will just
highlight four of them first one was get
more data
second one is build as many models as we
can
third one is double down on our data
points some of the data points that in
b2b model we have not looked at it like
user behavior user interactions some
places we are good in the company some
places we are not how do we make that as
a practice get that data to enable the
better working models for our for our
stakeholders and the fourth thing is not
only building the models giving you to
the users but how do we drive that
personalization that sense you talked
about a real dynamic personalization
where we can integrate these data
science models all these AI techniques
like energy and chat pod person you
talked about in our real user experience
across the different channels we know
that historically we always used
where the customer was now what we want
to know is where the customer will be
and what do we need to suggest to that
customer and if that customer is taking
a different action that anima the change
that recommendation and my
recommendation is not only product
recommendation it's about what we show
them what we want to bring to their
attention and what actions do we want to
drive based on those interactions so
based on this requirements when we
looked at what do we really need
technically to do those things we need a
in why we needed an environment over our
our our excellent environment within
Cisco which can scale for lot of data
where the data ingestion and integration
is is easier it's not too complicated we
have a dynamic way where we can generate
this data science model and deploy them
effectively and fourth thing is how can
we put a micro services around this data
science environments which which can
provide the concurrent a be test
pre-built in it so that this whole
environment could come together and help
our experience end-to-end this was a
complicated ask we looked at multiple
vendors and then we we decided to go
with with Google Google cloud platform
and we will continue to use our internal
environment that we have but we are
going to supplement with this all trial
experiment that sandy mentioned on the
Google environment and bring those
learnings back in our experience how we
interact with with our customers and
when I say customer is the real
customers our sellers and our partners
all the three dimensions if you look at
our proposed our architecture that we
are working towards majority of these
pieces are already in place but like any
other company we have slow moving slow
changing data which we call as a
reference information and and fast paced
data which is transactional structure
and then we have lot of data sources
from our third party from our
application where events are enabled so
when we looked at it we try to come up
with different strategy of how to ingest
these data points within Google Cloud
and we are using pub/sub we are using
GCP as activity we are using the
real-time data data transfer as well and
putting that in the Google so we can we
can build those scalable models at a
scale and enable them through
micro-services environment so as since
you talked about we have implemented
energy we are taking it to Google cloud
we have we have all these data sources
which we have already moved to Google
cloud and we are working on on Apache be
pretty much pops up to to to take this
third-party events and bring in to
Google cloud so it can it can improve on
our or our data science capabilities and
enable that experience that we just
talked about if you are next-generation
firewall eyes and em customer of Cisco
you can see that difference even now we
have already taken the first step when
you log into cisco.com on those product
pages you will see those customization
and a lot of things are coming in future
pretty soon as we are moving on this
journey with this I would say there are
a lot of things that we did and some of
the things in the Google cloud as a POC
which we did was sentiment analysis
using Google's pre-built API so a lot of
google provides a environment where we
can analyze the phone call we can
analyze user behavior we can analyze a
sentiment based on what what we are
getting as a feedback from user that
provides us faster go to market and a
capability where we can we can
personalize and meet our objectives much
faster with this that wraps our session
stay tuned for Q&A and we will be back
in a minute
thank you
you
okay thanks for listening through the
session so far we see some questions
coming up and we'll take a few of them
but you know myself and Sanjeev will
tack him along to answer these the first
question is do you need large amount of
data to run AI predictions and
recommendations model
how can smaller businesses and less
customer data benefit from such models
as a general rule of thumb yes in the
larger the amount of data the better but
there's no definitive measure on how how
much exactly you need it's a blend of
knowing your business it's a blend of
what you are trying to build in your
model and what kind of insights you're
trying to get and is that enough pattern
in the data so there are these are some
of three or four key aspects that you
have to look at before judging whether
you have enough data or not in my
experience working with various
customers worklets extremely large
literally like the fortune ten to the
extremely small which is like SMB and
and interestingly you know like
depending on the business urgency and
need both the spectrum of businesses use
machine learning and for example online
retailers as they call online retailer
extremely small business but extremely
fast in adopting machine learning with
streaming data of customer reviews and
so on other spectrum the large
enterprises also look for this because
their massive amount of data so that's
overall answer for that question
so sons you want to take the next
question yeah so the next question is
what data elements is Cisco looking for
to increase customer experience so I'd
say two big things come to mind
generally speaking so one is data that
comes from customer interactions I mean
that's should be pretty obvious but
let's take WeChat in which is we're
getting bigger and bigger in China so
you know as we're engaging with
customers on WeChat we really should
have a way to make sure that that data
is coming back into Cisco and we're
making sure that we're doing something
with that data with the thought that
that data should improve the experience
and engagement in other channels right
so that's one set of things the other
side of things is actually data from our
products so we collect a huge amount of
back from our products and increasingly
as we're adding more and more products
to our portfolio
especially in the software space that's
growing so a big part of what we're
trying to do is make sure that as that
data is coming back we can use that to
improve the experience and to
personalize it if we know for example
the customers are trying to implement
certain features for example then we
should be able to use that it'll in a
way to help them so they can get value
from their products that much faster
ok thanks Andy so see the next question
this has two three parts to it huh how
do we make sure companies are getting
maximum revenue using AI from marketing
perspective how to validate the results
and how to make sure you have the right
data while training the model this is a
pretty loaded question I'll have it in
my cell phone so you will will answer
this first of all ROI remember I
mentioned early on that machine learning
and AI projects are a journey and not a
project so keep that in mind if I told
you 15 years back or rather in 1995
internet is gonna change every aspect of
your enterprise and the work for most
enterprise it would be pretty hard to
imagine how that would be and today
nobody debates that you have to keep
that kind of perspective when you invest
in machine learning and AI don't expect
quick returns or magic here there is no
magic and and and it's a collective
learning of Google and many similar
companies that is now available for you
to learn now when you build machine
learning models to validate the result
keep one rule of thumb in mind you're
mimicking a human decision-making in
other words humans already make a lot of
decisions sitting at their desk if you
take a business problem of forecasting
for example how do you know that the
machine learning is predicting better
than you you train the model you
evaluate the model during the evaluation
phase check whether it's doing better
than humans then you have your answer
right and and there's as you go into
building machine learning model you'll
understand this even better and the last
thing is how do you make sure you have a
right data
there is this concept of clean data that
you hear very often in enterprise and
and fundamentally I don't believe in
clean data right as a data exists the
way they are
imagine if Google were to set up clean
every single data that gets entered
they'll never be able to get you the
results right with that perspective I'm
not saying don't clean the data data
preparation takes 60 to 70 percent of
time building machine learning models
but what more important is don't try to
make it perfect you know keep moving it
along you know let the model run let the
model also tell you few things that you
can improvise on since you do want to
add anything to it I totally agree with
your perspective actually Manju that's
correct
right you want to pick the next one sure
so the next question was will the models
that you're developing tell the humans
or virtual sales in real time with who
to target and how does it improve
conversion rate so you know another
another question that has many different
aspects to it I think what I'm honing in
on in this word real time right so yes
the models will tell human beings whom
to target we were doing that already
today the real-time piece is the one
that we're working towards so for
example let's say the best case scenario
manju you know you're a customer of
Cisco's and you come to Facebook and you
go hey I want to buy a Cisco router I
would love to put that in someone's
hands right away and we're not at that
point yet right so we're working towards
how do we get things into the hands of
salespeople as quickly as possible when
we know that there are opportunities to
do so in terms of how does it improve
conversion rate we we don't have a
specific metrics around sort of how is
conversion rate improved from before or
after but it's one of the things that
we're looking at is just general at this
point anecdotal feedback from sales
right are they finding a value in what
we're providing them do they is it
generally leading to sort of better
outcomes or not and and so far the
feedback has been very positive so
that's been great and I'll take the last
one as well sure go ahead yeah so the
last question is how important is
accuracy in the models that you're
developing and what are the ways to
increase the accuracy of the propensity
model so that's a great question and in
fact maybe the answer might be a little
bit encounter into
in that we are not overly concerned
about accuracy in the models at least
initially right our goal is to build
models and put them out there and to
learn from them and so sometimes you
know a lot of focus is placed especially
when you're involved in something like
Kaggle right data science competitions
how do you improve the accuracy from
seventy four point one to seventy four
point two and that's a huge improvement
we don't operate in that in that kind of
mindset our mindset is let's build a
model it's put it out there let's see
how it does is it is it doing something
that we think will advance the customer
experience in some way and then over
time iteratively let's continue to
improve it by getting more data by
refining the model itself and finding
out what works right that is the fastest
way for us to be able to make and of the
roadmap that we talked about a reality
so that's how I'd answer that question
right thanks Angie and the last comment
from Oz is you have when you start the
journey start started in a small way
learn experiment Google will help you
along with laura7 you can connect a
workshop with an initial model and get
started with the journey and from there
on there's a lot of learning that comes
into your enterprise and and have fun
thanks Angie and Vikram and with that
stay tuned for the next session which is
on from hi to value how to start machine
learning projects upon topic as well
thank you
you